[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
édition du grand jt des territoires
aussi tout de suite les titres de
l'actualité avec tout d'abord à la une
les conséquences du conflit en ukraine
dans les vosges un supermarché russe
devait ouvrir en ce mois d'avril mais
pour l'heure les rideaux restent baissés
un reportage de vosges télévision dès le
début de ce journal attirer les plus
jeunes et les convaincre de s'engager
dans le milieu médical le samu de
toulouse tente de séduire des lycéens
via occitanie a embarqué à bord d'un
hélicoptère lors d'une opération de
séduction vous verrez
187 mètres de long et 5 m'a le plus
grand voilier du monde était de passage
sur les côtes girondines un événement
exceptionnel et une première que n'a pas
manqué la rédaction de télé 7 la chaîne
du groupe sud ouest
laventure koh lanta comme si vous y
étiez mais dans les yvelines un parc de
loisirs vient d'inaugurer sa nouvelle
attraction dédié à la célèbre émission
et visiteurs doivent désormais choisir
leur camp rouge ou jaune la rédaction de
tv 78 elle a choisi vous verrez c'est
l'une des conséquences de la guerre
menée par la russie en ukraine certaines
entreprises russes peine 1 désormais à
s'installer en france c'est le cas par
exemple dans les vosges où un magasin
d'alimentation devait ouvrir il ya
quelques jours pour l'heure l'ouverture
est repoussé pour des raisons notamment
d'ordre public vous allez le voir
explications d'aurélie colombelles et de
nicholas bray d'art pour vosges
télévision
initialement le magasin mére devaient
ouvrir à sainte marguerite le 2 avril
mais la commune est devenue frileuse à
l'idée de l'installation d'une telle
enseigne une motion de report de
l'ouverture a été adopté en conseil
municipal le 8 mars dernier un gant un
risque de trouble à l'ordre public lors
de l'inauguration
une création d'emplois il ya aussi et ça
ce je conçois très bien que certaines
certains ménages ont des difficultés de
fin de mort et que
dans un magasin à bas prix pouvaient été
très intéressant poule mais il faut
faire la part des choses aussi est ce
que on peut accepter d'un côté nous
commune d'accueillir des familles
ukrainienne puisque à ce jour il ya deux
femmes ukrainiennes qui sont sûres sur
sainte marguerite et d'un autre côté
avoir 20 magasins russes qui s'installe
depuis juin dernier donc bien avant le
début de la guerre lancée news russe
loup cette cellule commerciale
l'ouverture de septembre 2021 est
repoussée faute de mise en conformité et
d'aléas administratif finalement des
travaux débutés les premières palettes
serait à l'intérieur mais un autre frein
vient d'être activé les terrasses sur
lequel mairet doit s'installer nous
étions propriétaires de ces terrains et
nous avons fait une cession de ces
terrains en 2006 et dans les clauses de
cette vente c'était bien stipulé qu
aucune surface alimentaire pendant 20
ans ne pouvait s'installer
à cet endroit là en dépit de nos
sollicitations l'enseigne n'a pas
souhaité s'exprimer il semblerait malgré
tout qu elles subissent au niveau
national des difficultés
d'approvisionnement et des contraintes
financières
il est ou non aux sanctions instaurées
depuis le début de la guerre les deux
autres mairies qui devait ouvrir sur le
territoire national sont également au
point mort
la situation en ukraine qui impacte
aussi vous le savez le prix de l'essence
le cours du pétrole s'est envolé depuis
le début de la guerre est un secteur
d'activité particulièrement touché celui
de la logistique et des transporteurs
routiers pour y faire face des
entreprises cherchent des solutions pour
atténuer leur facture de carburant
exemple à roanne avec christophe rigaud
au regard d
un plein de gasoil qui coûte de plus en
plus cher chez ce transporteur routier
la facture s'est envolé et chaque mois
le prix du carburant est scrutée à la
loupe si à titre de comparaison je
prends il ya cinq ans
2017 on avait une moyenne à 0 98 72 si
je prends la moyenne sur les trois
premiers mois en tout cas 2022 on est à
1 euro 50
1 50 55 le prix du gasoil hors taxes le
litre sur un plein en euros
c'est équivalent d'une centaine d'euros
largement si les transporteurs routiers
peuvent légalement répercuter cette
hausse sur leurs factures cette
situation met tout un secteur économique
sous pression et c'est difficile
aujourd'hui commercialement
il ya eu nos clients viennent des fois
pas vers l'eau pour vous demander
également d'essayer de limiter cette
hausse gasoil malheureusement on essaie
de faire ce que l'on veut mais si on
sait quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas
toucher parce que aujourd'hui l'on ne
fait pas de l'argent sur un piètre
facture gasoil alors pour limiter sa
facture de carburant cette entreprise a
décidé d'être plus vigilante sur la
consommation des véhicules notamment en
optimisant certains trajets mais aussi
en pratiquant l'éco conduite c'est une
conduite qui est plus écologique et plus
économique
c'est
c'est pouvoir doser son accélération
c'est un suivi du matériel du moteur à
voir le moteur bien réglé et c'est
également du coup savoir se servir de
son véhicule de la façon la plus
optimale possible donc se servir du
régulateur ou à l'assistance au freinage
la pression des pneumatiques est
particulièrement surveillé ce véhicule
peut économiser jusqu'à 13 % de
carburant avec une bonne pression de ses
pneus
frédéric dabi le directeur général du
pôle opinion de l'ifop était l'invité
jeudi matin de l'émission face aux
territoires sur tv5 monde il est
notamment revenu sur le rôle joué par
les instituts de sondages durant ces
élections regardez ce qu'il a dit
six mois avant les élections
présidentielles 60% des français rejeté
emmanuel macron
le deuxième tour a eu lieu il ya
quelques jours dimanche dernier soixante
pour cent des français ont voté pour lui
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ça montre
châssis raid une faute plus que la
popularité n'est pas le vote vous avez
raison et ben macron a été un président
impopulaire c'est à dire il a une
majorité de permis c'est compréhensible
par exemple par le groupe à tonnerre de
la france mais sks coût énorme et on
nous regarde pas un peu curieusement
mais vous savez la popularité dans une
période de crise c'est extrêmement
compliqué mais je retourne votre
remarque est complètement juste six mois
avant son élection dans tous les
indicateurs et fortune nous avons trois
indicateurs de popularité 1 avec paris
match est le plus ancien la 5ème
république du journal du dimanche il
était à 42 43 % de personnes satisfaites
c'était nettement plus que tous ses
prédécesseurs sauf les présidents qui
était encore en cohabitation il avait il
a un socle de popularité minoritaire
mais un bloc important voilà pour voir
ou revoir l'émission face aux
territoires diffusée sur tv5 monde
rendez vous sur les sites internet des
partenaires de l'émission ouest france
nice matin et vingt minutes dans le
reste de l'actualité la fin d'une lutte
qui aura duré cent cinquante quatre
jours celle des ex salariés de la
fonderie sam dans l'aveyron il occupait
le site de leur usine depuis cinq mois
pour en assurer la protection
l'émotion et les larmes coulaient sur
les visages au moment de quitter pour la
dernière fois lusine comme vous le voyez
sur ces images de nos confrères de la
dépêche du midi sur place de la
tristesse donc mais aussi de la fierté
et de l'espoir pour leur avenir propos
recueillis par clément gaci sur place
nalcor céret et bah voila quoi ces
fuites
c'est terminé mais on reviendra comme je
disais mon collègue john
j'espère depuis 23 ans reviendra et puis
on reprendra une place le nom de projet
industriel on s'est battu pour
et on ne sait pas si nombre d'entre nous
seront repris mais bon j'espère que
maintenant on entre nous sont reprises
dans cette usine j'espère revenir voilà
du courage pour ses salariés donc et une
solidarité non sans lien avec l'histoire
d'un jeune malien dans la sarthe doug il
a 20 ans s'est intégré il travaille et a
même un cdi pourtant en situation
irrégulière depuis sa majorité il risque
l'expulsion
l'agricultrice avec lequel il travaille
depuis trois ans se bat pour qu'il
dispose de papiers à reportage d'anthony
python pour lm tv sartre sur place
gvt est un
je suis né lé 5 octobre des moulins il
s'appelle douga et travaille dans cette
ferme depuis trois ans à coulans sur gée
d'abord stagiaire puis apprentis ce
malien est aujourd'hui en cdi pourtant
depuis sa majorité il est en situation
irrégulière la préfecture refuse de
reconnaître la validité de son état
civil je n'ai plus le droit d travail
j'en appelle un patron mais dire ça il
faut qu'elle arrête d'ébaucher avec moi
quoi ou bien arrêter tout quoi sa
patronne et loïse a choisi de le
soutenir et de le garder comme apprenti
puis de l'embauché chaque mois elle paye
son salaire et ses cotisations pourtant
lui n'a aucun droit je les forme et
pendant de quasi deux ans
d'apprentissage donc j'ai envie de
continuer avec lui il travaille
extrêmement bien il est toujours à
l'heure il est extrêmement respectueux
c'est quelqu'un avec qui je passe des
très bonne journée on est très
complémentaires il est sérieux là là où
ils habitent c'est pareil les gens
adorent quand c'est quelqu'un de bien
quoi ya pas trop à tourner autour du pot
et puis je me voyais pas le laisser tout
seul dehors en sachant qu'en plus
dougan a pas eu d'obligation de quitter
le territoire
depuis il se bat pour tenter de
régulariser sa situation
un courrier a été envoyé à la préfecture
sans réponse c'est un tld faire pas mal
d activité que j'ai envie de faire comme
les autres quoi pain qui gens qui ont
des papiers mais mais mais jamie
principe c'est qu'ils font mais magique
et moi quoi dont le futur doug aimerait
passer son permis et s'inscrire dans une
salle de sport des activités impossible
sans titre de séjour
comment faire face à la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre dans le monde de la médecine
pour répondre à cette question le samu
de toulouse s'adresse directement aux
étudiants et tente de les séduire vous
allez le voir une journée dans la peau
d'un professionnel permet à des lycéens
de se projeter et d'envisager pourquoi
pas d'embrasser une carrière médicale
stéphanie forgeois pour la rédaction
devient occitanie
opération séduction réussie pour le samu
de toulouse des élèves de première et de
terminale du lycée de saint céré dans le
lot on assister à une visite guidée des
différents services les dix neuf élèves
inscrits en option santé peuvent ainsi
se préparer à l'entrée en école de
médecine salut c'est un service du
centre hospitalier universitaire donc on
est habitué à former les jeunes on a
tout le temps des jeunes et notre
vocation en tant qu enseignant en
médecine d'urgence bien c'est aussi
d'accueillir ces jeunes donc il ya une
vraie robe boucle qui se fait là avec le
chu qui est un centre d'accueil et de
formation d'excellence et puis ce
souhait de la région de former les
jeunes le but de cette opération est
aussi de séduire ses élèves à
s'implanter en milieu rural une idée qui
tentent ces jeunes jeunes ravis de leur
journée immersive ils ont pu essayer
détenus et même monter dans
l'hélicoptère
ces dépassements j'aime bien faire des
stages à la base donc ça me permet de
découvrir et de voir mais ce qui se
passe réellement j'ai toute ma famille
ici et la ville je trouve que c'est un
lieu un peu spéciale où il ya beaucoup
de monde et tout et je préfère la
campagne s'est plus posé et puis il ya
moins de médecins aussi moi je sais que
je l'aimerais bien faire tes d'y être et
je sais qu il en manque donc ça me fait
pas trop peur pour le moment 80% de la
région aussi thani et en zone de tension
médical si le lot n'est pas encore
considérée comme désert médical le
département manque cruellement de
médecins il faudrait cinq à six
praticiens par an pour renouveler les
départs à la retraite et ce dans les
cinq prochaines années
du manque de médecins au manque de
commerces dans les zones rurales dans ce
gîte et dans le val d'oise vous allez
voir un food trucks se déplacent de
village en village pour venir au contact
des habitants créée l'an dernier il
propose des frites et des burgers fait à
partir de produits 100% locaux et pour
compléter l'offre de restauration le
propriétaire a lancé récemment un camion
épicerie objectif répondre au manque de
distribution alimentaire dans les
communes rurales un reportage de
reillanne belli pour vient 95
ce mardi soir mais big thing trucks
s'arrête à en ville village de moins de
700 habitants ces camions restaurant
s'installe chaque soir dans une petite
commune du vexin proposer des frites et
des burgers fait à partir de produits
100% locaux pour commandes' admire
l'ancien réparateur de voitures bricoler
lui même ses camions pour en faire des
food trucks en 2021 un an après son
réseau constitué d'une vingtaine de
producteurs commence à porter ses fruits
ce qui est compliqué c'est
l'approvisionnement c'est sûr parce que
bon forcément leaf les fournisseurs ne
seront pas toujours au même endroit on
est limite 78 limite l'oise et cetera ça
nous permet de visiter pas mal de
village mais c'est très compliqué de
s'approvisionner mais maintenant il ya
un petit et un petit rendement voilà
depuis décembre un camion épicerie a
rejoint le camion restauration déjà
existants ils l'accompagnent plusieurs
jours par semaine pour répondre au
manque de distribution alimentaire en
territoire rural charcuteries fromages
miels outardes l'épicerie tenue par un
ami d'enfance du patron propose une
large palette de produits aux qu on
n'avait pas te qui vient de barbares 60
on a des fromages des yaourts vient de
de rosé dans 78 et limitrophes on veut
lever que ça on veut la croix peint on
veut les petits producteurs en fait on
ne peut pas les grandes surfaces les
habitants d'aaron ville sont pour la
plupart ravis de cette initiative
si on n'a pas grand chose dans le
village qu'ils puissent faire des choses
comme ça à part le restaurant aussi
qu'on a d'un village qui est bien donc
ça fait un petit plus le jour où il son
pari moi qui suis vraiment viande à bien
votre ce qui vient de tout ce qui est
saucisses le pâté les fromages aussi
moi je cherche le fromage de vache
ça donne envie ça donne envie les
victimes trucks devrait continuer
prochainement à se développer avec
l'installation d'un troisième camion
aussi dédié à la restauration
voilà nous partons pour monaco où les 29
policiers du groupe de protection de
surveillance et d'intervention dispose
de tout nouveaux locaux plus
fonctionnels ceci leur permettront
notamment de mieux assurer leur mission
dans la principauté l'inauguration s'est
faite en présence vous le voyez du
prince souverain images et réactions
recueillies par fabien bonne il ya pour
monaco info
ce groupe d'intervention de monaco donc
l'équivalent on va dire que c'est leur
aide mais bien évidemment par rapport à
monaco nous avons aussi d'autres
missions qui sont des missions de voie
publique généraliste on va dire qui
consiste à sécuriser par nos compétences
peut-être de manière un peu plus poussée
la voie publique c'est tout bête mais 29
personnes il faut des vestiaires on a
beaucoup de matériel on a aussi beaucoup
de matériel d'équipement d'armement donc
ça permet de se sentir à l'aise
confortable et surtout de pouvoir avoir
aussi
conforter le sentiment de cohésion voilà
tout à fait autre chose dans l'actualité
nous découvrons à présent une activité
peu connue celle d' affûteur rémouleur
un métier exercice par renault sorèze
dans le nord de la france dans son
atelier mobile une camionnette aménagée
cet ancien cadre commercial aiguise
restaure et entretient les lames que lui
confient particuliers et restaurateurs
un savoir-faire aussi technique que
minutieux aussi exigeant vous allez le
voir que fascinant jérémy ouvrons pour
ueo tv la chaîne de la voix du nord
équipé de sa mallette il a tout d'un
réparateur mais c'est une intervention
bien particulière qui amène aujourd'hui
renaud sorel a poussé la porte de ce
restaurant de camon à vélo
les couteaux du chef sont émoussées un
peu d'affûtage s'impose
ça marche renault est affûteur rémouleur
il y a un an cet ancien cadre commercial
plaque sa vie professionnelle pour se
lancer dans ce métier artisanal
dans son atelier mobile ils s'affairent
à rendre à nos ustensiles leur tranchant
et c'est assez technique donc je fume
d'abord là dessus donc je vais recréer
le tranchant de chaque côté et créer ce
qu'on appelle un morphil le morphil
c'est la petite limaille qui reste au
bout du fil convient crée ensuite la
deuxième étape donc c'est là dessus
c'est sur ma main je vais enlever le mot
refile donc c'est ce qu'on appelle les
morts filage outils de jardin couteau de
cuisine l'âme de tondeuses renaud sorel
peut presque tout restaurer il faut
juste s'adapter chaque jour c'est
différent j'ai fait des couteaux de
presse agricole et j'ai fait aussi une
grosse lame de trancheuses à pain pour
un boulanger donc pareil fallait et je
cherche un petit peu comment j'allais là
prendre parce que c'est ces encombrants
c'est une grande dame comme ça en 30
minutes le set de couteau est quasiment
prêt à l'emploi place au test ultime je
passe juste un coût de chaque côté pour
mettre le fil droit
et après on teste
voilà alors attention aux doigts dans la
somme une dizaine de restaurateurs font
appel aux compétences de renault
racheter des outils de travail et
coûteux et les affûteur rémouleur ne
courent pas les rues quand on a vu qu'il
était présent sur le marché on a sauté
dessus quoi je veux dire un bon artisan
travaille avec des bons outils bon
cuisinier travailler avec des mon
couteau donc
et pour que ce soit bien aiguisé
le mieux c'est de faire appel à
quelqu'un qui s'y connaît vraiment et et
qui sait sans métier quand la france ne
compte que quelques 250 affûteur
rémouleur c'est un savoir-faire en voie
de disparition pourtant renaud sorel en
est certain il a fait le bon choix il en
mettrait même sa main à couper
voilà c'est un instrument presque
monuments historiques un piano steinway
fabriqué à new york en 1859 qui est
actuellement utilisé par les élèves et
les professeurs du conservatoire de
limoges il permet aux pianistes
d'entendre comme à l'époque la
reproduction exacte du sont imaginés au
moment de l'écriture d'une oeuvre
l'instrument est évidemment l'objet de
toutes les attentions des pianistes
locaux à reportage de benjamin delmas
pour 7 à limoges
des touches d'ivoire patiner une table
d'harmonie sans fin plus que centenaire
ce stand est américain fait puissamment
sonné ce prélude et fugue de jean
sébastien bach
on clavier et midi ancien élève et
musiciennes du conservatoire ne boude
pas son plaisir de jouer sur un tel
instrument c'est très agréable de jouer
dessus le son est très différent et le
toucher aussi c'est particulier parce
que en fonction de la tessiture on a des
textures de sont extrêmement différentes
et c'est très enrichissant aussi pour
comprendre comment écrivez les
compositeurs en fonction des époques et
en fonction des des fabricants de piano
en fait moi j'ai comptabilisé il nous
faudrait
et au minimum cinq pianos historique qui
nous permettent de couvrir les périodes
de l'histoire de la musique sortie
d'usiné new yorkaise steinway en 1859 ce
piano a été jouée par des générations de
musiciens accordé par un passionné il
retrouve ses sonorités d'antan l'accord
d'un piano c'est pas une opération qui
consiste à mettre une aiguille au milieu
d'un d'un écran
c'est mettre un corps sonores
en harmonie avec l'univers à un moment
donné dans un lieu donné pour une
personne donnée la corse et rechercher
en permanence au niveau des émotions au
niveau du ressenti la justesse
une chose est sûre les pianos
historiques comme ceux steinway ne
demande qu'à être joué que ce pour
longtemps encore
une page sports à présent dans ce
journal connaissez vous le foot fauteuil
il s'agit de la version handisport du
football sur le terrain huit joueurs
sont présents équipés de fauteuils ultra
rapide et maniable un sport avec ses
entraînements intensifs ces sélections
et sa coupe du monde elle se prépare
d'ailleurs en ce moment même avec les
sélections pour l'équipe de france et en
bretagne deux joueurs font partie de la
liste xavier pâte rajon pour la chaîne
tébéo la chaîne du groupe le télégramme
a suivi l'un de leurs entraînements
regarder
restons le beller et vincent le québec
font partie des merlus de kerpape et ils
sont sélectionnés pour intégrer l'équipe
de france de foot fauteuil en ligne de
mire la coupe du monde et d'ici là il
faut franchir chaque étape de la
sélection du travail
travail doit son coach dresse
coéquipiers qu'on a avec vous
on s'améliore et abandonné ya quelque
chose si pays
les portes des coupes de france allait
tout doucement sur le terrain huit
joueurs un ballon et de buts c'est comme
du foot valide
juste en faute et on a importé un ballon
avec des risques spécifiques avec
discipline capot
les spectateurs justement c'est une
vraie question du handisport comment le
rendre visible car il ya tellement à
gagner alors les élections pour l'équipe
de france font partie des occasions ça
apporte la visibilité sur le moment mais
c'est pas c'est pas énorme par rapport
aux sports valide c'est quand même
quelque chose qui reste dans les saps un
peu obscure quant à elle à kerpape c'est
d'ailleurs presque habituelle de faire
partie de cette short list alors la
pression ou pas on ne sera de tout faire
pour rester dans ces 10 jusqu'à la coupe
du monde
qui est prévu 1 2023 en attendant
tristan et vincent participeront au
prochain stage de sélection organisé mi
avril au centre de kerpape à ploemeur il
est si haut qu'il lui est impossible de
passer sous le pont d'aquitaine le
voilier à cinq mâts club med 2 2 était
en escale en gironde la semaine dernière
le temps d'une nuit pour découvrir le
paysage de la région nouvelle aquitaine
une première pour les passagers en
excursion mais également pour le plus
grand voilier au monde yvan branchies
pour tv7 la chaîne du groupe sud ouest a
pu monter à bord regarder
un dernier signal et le club med de
largue les amarres après une escale de
24 heures au port de grattequina de
parempuyre cap sur le verdon à présent
en remontant l'estuaire de la gironde
c'est des grands coefficients donc on a
beaucoup de courant et donc il faut être
vigilant le bateau dérape rapidement il
est sur son tapis roulant le début d'un
long périple vers le portugal suivie de
près par les habitants qui profitent du
spectacle le plus grand voilier du monde
de passage à bordeaux ce n'est pas tous
les jours et c'est même la première fois
de l'histoire bordeaux at elle une telle
aura que c'était vraiment dommage de ne
pas essayer de creuser ce point et de se
dire bien pourquoi ne pas venir à
bordeaux
[Musique]
2700 mètres carré de peau en teck 187
mètres de long 5 mâts sept voiles un
lieu d'une capacité de 350 passagers qui
navigue depuis trente ans entre les
caraïbes et la méditerranée mais cette
année le voilier découvrent la région et
découvre également de nouveaux passagers
on a même et ça c'est une petite
particularité embarquer des bordelais
qui sont venus nous rejoindre lisbonne
simplement pour avoir le plaisir de
pouvoir avoir un nouveau regard sur leur
très belle région mais par la mer ou par
le club une fois la croisière terminée
le club med 2 repartira sur nice son
port d'attache pour préparer la
prochaine saison maritime et pourquoi
pas jeter l'ancré de nouveau sur la
région
vous êtes des millions à la regarder
chaque semaine l'émission koh lanta
fascine autant qu'elle amuse depuis
quelques jours d'ailleurs dans les
yvelines il est désormais possible de
s'essayer à quelques une des épreuves
les plus mythiques de l'émission dans le
parc france miniature une aventure et un
sujet de la rédaction de tv 78 la chaîne
des yvelines
plus nécessaire d'envoyer sa candidature
pour se défier sous les couleurs des
tribus jaune ou rouge un espace de jeu
koh lanta inaugurée dans le parc france
miniature par l'une des figures
emblématiques de la célèbre émission
clémence castel dans cet univers on
retrouve l'univers koh lanta évidemment
et toutes les épreuves qui vont avec il
ya une épreuve de chasse au trésor c'est
un milieu très très aquatique donc
forcément dans koh lanta on retrouve de
l'eau que ce soit sur les plages ou même
par la pluie malheureusement parfois
petits et grands pourront traverser les
bambous dans le but d'en sortir le moins
30 est possible jusqu'à l'affrontement
final sur la mythique épreuve des
poteaux pour tous les les fans de
l'émission ben voilà ils vont retrouver
tout tout ce qui entoure et tout ce qui
fait rêver dans koh lanta c'est à dire
laventure le dépassement de soi et je
suis sûr que plus les familles vont
passer un très bon moment dans cet
univers un espace pensé avec alp la
société de production de koh lanta l'a
fallu à peu près un nom en termes de
conception entre la réflexion et la
l'inauguration il avait déjà travaillé
ensemble sur le précédent lieu
thématique du park l'antre du père
fouras du fort boyard inauguré en 2010
est notre constance c'est de garder des
marqueurs qui sont pour les familles ça
se voit à partager entre enfants
transgénérationnel ça c'est notre marque
heures et qui soit un côté ludique et
pédagogique mais en tout cas on veut
qu'ils aient des sensations des émotions
du partage il faudra donc compter sur ce
détour des paysans pour visiter le parc
117 monument à petite échelle car sa
présence est irrévocable
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve très
vite pour une prochaine édition du grand
jt des territoires au revoir à tous
[Musique]